[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport
es gibt neues in der flugblattaffäre
Söder hält eiwanger im
zdf-sommer-interview begründet Bayerns
Ministerpräsident seine Entscheidung
Überschwemmungen in Spanien nach der
Hitze kommt das Unwetter bis morgen soll
es weiter regnen
und WM durch Marsch der deutschen
Basketballer gegen die Slowenen
erkämpfen Sie sich den Gruppensieg
[Musik]
eine Entlassung Hubert aiwangers wäre
nicht verhältnismäßig sagt Bayerns
Ministerpräsident Söder auch weil es
keinen Beweis gäbe dass sein Vize vor 35
Jahren das antisemitische Flugblatt
erstellt oder verbreitet habe um
verloren gegangenes Vertrauen aufzubauen
soll Aiwanger mit jüdischen Gemeinden
sprechen mattes
es ist ein hochkonzentrierter CSU-Chef
und Ministerpräsident der da zum
zdf-sommer-interview kommt Markus Söder
Arndt wohl dass die flugblattaffäre und
der Umgang damit durch Hubert Aiwanger
auch seine Macht bedrohen könnte am
Morgen hat er in einer eilig
einberufenen Pressekonferenz seinem
Stellvertreter zunächst das Vertrauen
ausgesprochen der Gesamtabwägung
das kein Beweis vorliegt dass die Sache
35 Jahre her ist und das seitdem nichts
Vergleichbares vorgefallen ist wäre eine
Entlassung aus dem Amt
aus meiner Sicht nicht verhältnismäßig
Söder veröffentlicht zusätzlich die 25
Fragen und Antworten an und von Hubert
Aiwanger fast ein Drittel beantwortet
der freie wählerchef mit ich kann mich
nicht erinnern
im Sommer Interview begründet Markus
Söder seine Entscheidung auch mit einem
persönlichen Gespräch mit Aiwanger der
müsste sich jetzt bemühen seine
demokratische Haltung zu beweisen ich
hatte das Gefühl dass auch seinen
so eine Reue und auch seine seine
Distanzierung von dem Flugblatt und dem
Inhalt des Flugplatz des
zugegebenermaßen ekelhaft widerlich und
reiner nazi-charger es war für mich
glaubhaft am Ende Kritik der
bundesinnenministerin die von einem
Schaden fürs Land spricht weiß zu oder
zurück aber auch VertreterInnen der
jüdischen Gemeinde erwarten jetzt das
Aiwanger Vertrauen wieder herstellt dazu
hat Söder seinem Stellvertreter eine Art
Nachhilfeunterricht verordnet ein
Gespräch mit den jüdischen Gemeinden
deswegen glaube ich ist es einfach
zwingend notwendig sich mit diesem Thema
auch selbst glaubhaft zu beschäftigen
und nicht nur zu sagen ich bin dagegen
sondern auch im Gespräch das glaubhaft
zu dokumentieren dann könne man nach der
Wahl die Koalition mit den Freien
Wählern fortsetzen auch mit Hubert
alberner Söder betont ist ging um eine
Fähre und abgewogene Entscheidung die
nach seiner Auffassung Schaden vom Land
abwenden soll
Stefan Leif hat in München die
Opposition sagt Söder habe aus reinem
macht Kalkül so entschieden
na jedenfalls rettet Markus Söder mit
diesem Schritt von heute seine Koalition
aus CSU und Freien Wählern über die
nächsten fünf Wochen bis zum Wahltag er
umgeht damit den für ihn sehr
unangenehmen Schritt auf die
Oppositionsparteien zu meinen neuen
Koalitionspartner zu finden und vor
allem vielleicht ist das sogar ein
wichtigsten aus CSU sich die CSU muss
jetzt nicht ihre komplette
Wahlkampfstrategie über Bord werfen denn
die bestand vor allem darin für eine
Fortsetzung der Koalition aus CSU und
Freien Wählern zu werben aber Markus
Söder geht mit der Entscheidung von
heute auch ein großes Risiko ein denn ab
jetzt ist jeder Zweifel der und Hubert
awanger weiter besteht auch an Zweifel
der Markus söderhaft Söder hat ja die
Latte enorm hochgehängt und
zweifelsfreie Aufklärung gefordert dass
er jetzt bekommen hat ist ein Antwort
Katalog mit vielen Antworten die große
Löcher und Erinnerungslücken aufweisen
also Markus Söder verknüpft heute das
Schicksal der CSU mit der
Glaubwürdigkeit von Hubert Aiwanger und
das ist fünf Wochen vor der Landtagswahl
ein ziemlich riskanter Schritt danke
schön für diese Einschätzung aus München
Stefan leifert war das das
sommerinterview mit dem bayerischen
Ministerpräsidenten sehen Sie direkt
nach diesen Nachrichten und auch die 25
Fragen und aiwangers Antworten können
Sie bei uns nachlesen auf ZDF heute und
in der App
militärische Fortschritte das meldet die
Ukraine seit Tagen ein General bestätigt
nun die erste russische
Verteidigungslinie in der Region
saporicia sei durchbrochen
unterdessen Griff Russland in der Region
Odessa Hafen Infrastruktur an die
wichtig für den Getreideexporte ist
morgen treffen sich cremeschiff Putin
und der türkische Präsident Erdogan um
über die Rückkehr zum getreideabkommen
zu sprechen
Papst franziskus hat seine
mongolei-reise fortgesetzt Tag drei
stand ganz im Zeichen der
interreligiösen Verständigung gemeinsam
mit Vertretern anderer
Glaubensrichtungen rief franziskus zu
Harmonie zwischen den Religionen auf
danach feierte er mit mehr als 2000
Gläubigen die Messe unter ihnen auch
chinesische Katholiken die franziskus
explizit grüßte das kommunistische
Regime hatte Gläubigen verboten in die
Mongolei zu pilgern
über große Teile Spaniens ziehen seit
gestern schwere Unwetter vor allem der
Nordosten des Landes ist betroffen für
die katalanische Gemeinde alcanar wurde
wegen der Gefahr von Überschwemmungen
ein Ausgehverbot verhängt auch im
Gebieten in Andalusien und in der
Hauptstadt Madrid gilt Alarmstufe Rot
Thomas Walde berichtet
in castillion Bergen Feuerwehrleute
verlassene Fahrzeuge in El Romeral
stehen Garagen unter Wasser anwohner
berichten von plötzlichem
Wasser viel herab wie nie zuvor Wasser
kam überall herein Keller und Häuser
sind voller Schlamm in einigen gegen den
Spaniens Spielen über Nacht 130 Liter
pro Quadratmeter Madrids Behörden
erwarten dass der dortige regenrekord
von 1972 in der kommenden Nacht
gebrochen wird der Bürgermeister wendet
sich per Textnachricht an die Bewohner
mit einem Alarm
es ist eine ungewöhnliche eine
außergewöhnliche Situation was den Regen
betrifft und mein Rat und meine Bitte
sind dass die Menschen in Madrid zu
Hause bleiben und so wenig unterwegs
sind wie möglich
laut Meteorologen führen hohe
Wassertemperaturen und Verdunstungen in
den Mittelmeerraum zu Gewittern nach der
Hitze kommt der Regen in Spanien Sommer
der Wetter extreme
in Venedig feiert gerade das älteste
Filmfestival der Welt seinen 80sten
wegen der Streik sind Hollywood 24 viele
Superstars aber es läuft ein deutscher
Film im Wettbewerb Annette hilsenbeck
war auf der Premiere
roter Teppich für die Theorie von allem
von Regisseur Tim Kröger mit Jan Bülow
und Olivia Ross in den Hauptrollen
endlich wieder ein deutscher Film im
Wettbewerb um den Goldenen Löwen
es ist ein fantastisches Gefühl weil ich
das weil ich wirklich glaube dass die
Italiener und auch die anderen
verstanden haben was wir da gemacht
haben
der Thriller spielt 1962 in den Alpen
der jungphysiker Johannes Leinert reist
zu einem internationalen Kongress
alleinert arbeitet an seine Situation
wäre mit erfolglos ein Schüler ist immer
nur so gut wie sein Lehrer eine
mysteriöse Pianistin die erkennen lernt
verschwindet als ein Professor ermordet
wird immer mehr bizarres passiert leider
will dies ergründen und es bald nicht
mehr sicher was wirklich Realität ist
trotz der Gesetze der Physik das ist
eine Metapher für etwas was uns alle
interessiert nämlich die Frage nimmt
unser Leben den Verlauf den es nehmen
sollten oder könnte es sein dass wir
irgendwo falsch abbiegen und die Frage
nach Parallelwelten stellt implizit
diese Frage
starke Kontraste in Schwarz-Weiß eine
Dramatik die an Filme von Hitchcock oder
Edgar Wallace erinnert in deutsche Kinos
kommt der Film Ende Oktober
damit zum Sport bei der Basketball WM
läuft's bislang bestens fürs deutsche
Team Spiele 5 Siege Gruppen erster
souverän ins Viertelfinale eingezogen
und heute die Krönung einer perfekten
deutschen Hauptrolle 100 zu 71 gegen
Slowenien obwohl es anfangs gar nicht so
gut lief
hitzige teaminterne Diskussionen zu
Beginn das erste Viertel geht mit elf zu
25 verloren gegen Slowenien und deren
Superstar Luca doncic doch dann dreht
das deutsche Team unwiderstehlich auf
fast ein Sinnbild dafür diese Aktion
ihres Kapitäns Dennis Schröder dass die
Aufholjagd keine One-Man-Show ist zeigt
dieser Korb von Daniel theißt am Ende
ein klares hundert zu 71 Viertelfinale
Gegner Mittwoch ist Lettland
[Applaus]
zu den US Open da hat Alexander das wäre
auf das Achtelfinale in New York
erreicht durch einen 3:1 gegen den
Bulgaren Krieger Dimitroff
als Alexander Zverev im zweiten Satz
stürzt ist es gerade zu symbolhaft denn
Gregor Dimitroff ist bis dahin der
bessere von zwei sehr guten Spielern
doch der Hamburger findet zurück ins
Match und gewinnt Satz 2break da
Dimitrov fortan die Kräfte schwinden
fällt es wäre vielleicht seine physische
Überlegenheit auszuspielen und das Match
in vier zum Teil hochklassigen Sätzen zu
gewinnen im Achtelfinale wartet nun der
Weltranglisten 6 januar gegen den Zverev
sicher wieder bis an seine physischen
Grenzen gehen muss
zur EM im Springreiten da hat das
deutsche Team am letzten wettkampfdach
doch noch die ersehnte Medaille geholt
durch Philipp Weishaupt im Einzelfinale
Weißhaupt strahlt im Kreise der Familie
Silber bei der EM in Mailand
überglücklich wie gesagt seine neuen
Jahre alt hat sich von seiner
Zuckerseite gezeigt wie abgeklärt das
gemacht hat schon echt mega auf Sinne da
gelingen zwei fehlerlose Durchgänge im
anspruchsvollen Parcour des Hippodroms
Philipp Weishaupt zweiter nach dem
enttäuschenden vierten Platz mit dem
Team noch besser präsentieren sich in
Mailand nur Steve Gerda und dynamikste
Wilhelm Gold für den Schweizer 12 Jahre
nach seinem Olympiasieg Bronze gewinnt
der Franzose Julia
also ein persönlicher em-abschluss für
das deutsche Team dankeschön das Wetter
bleibt spätsommerlich und warm viel
Sonne und meist nur dünne hohe Wolken
die Temperatur steigt bei einem im Süden
lebhaften Ostwind auf 22 bis 30 Grad
Christian Sievers begrüßt sie um 21:45
Uhr im heute journal das heute Team sagt
danke und tschüss und wünscht Ihnen
einen guten Start in die neue